the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media get your tickets to the
night pants nation tour all right we got
it rolling off here already coming at
you all right baltimore october 23rd
brea california october 28th arlington
virginia november 12th and 13th
cleveland december 9th through the 11th
la jolla december 17th through the 19th
all right there are other dates up on
the website go to ryanstickler.com get
your tickets there's 20 22 dates up
there already but you can just go there
and see them all right the youtube
channel youtube.com uh go subscribe
please it means nothing to you and
everything to me all right you hit it
subscribe you're watching anyway just
hit the damn subscribe button it matters
all right it's free it's free you don't
have to buy [ __ ] you don't do anything
just hit that subscribe all right uh and
if you
can't just get enough honeydew once a
week you gotta hit that patreon up all
right it's the honeydew with y'all it's
five bucks a month that's it okay
you get the entire back catalog you also
get the honeydew a day early ad free at
no additional cost if you sign up for a
year you get over a month free all right
and
just recently
we had somebody
i mean come on man knight pants nation
is solving [ __ ] cold cases y'all who
else in comedy's out there their fan
bases are solving cold cases nobody five
bucks a month if you or someone you know
has that story that has to be heard
please submit it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com and hopefully we get to do an
episode with you all right uh the
honeydew podcast that's the website for
the show you get your merch the
ringtones are there you all ask for the
ringtones they are there all right now
that's the biz you guys know what we do
over here we highlight the low lights i
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers
uh i'm very excited to have here first
time on the honeydew y'all ladies and
gentlemen please welcome shay gillis
welcome to the honeydew hey man that's
great very nice to have you here thank
you man and your notre dame gear yes
are you a notre dame guy i'm a fan fan
yeah yeah yeah you did not go to notre
dame i did not all right no we're gonna
talk about a lot of [ __ ] sure uh but
before we do please plug promote
everything you'd like uh just put out a
special on youtube shane gillis uh live
in austin uh it's on gillian kiev's
youtube channel we got sketches on there
all that and uh matt and shane's secret
podcast
all right nice
um congrats on the special thank you
very much
right now it is and that's nice yeah so
i wanna we're gonna talk about obviously
snl all that stuff but before we get
into that like tell me a little bit
about you like where are you from
originally what's your upbringing like
all right uh i'm from mechanicsburg
pennsylvania
up the street yeah yeah it's close and
uh
i went to
middle class suburb
grew up uh
irish catholic family your parents
together at the time yeah still together
together okay good yeah and uh yeah went
to catholic school after that
went to college
you have brothers sisters two older
sisters two older sisters yeah all right
where'd you go to college i went to a
bunch uh i went to
i went to a bunch to get a bachelor's
degree in history
uh
it was tough
so i went after high school i went i
played football so i went to west point
all right you played football in high
school first played high school football
did you get recruited yeah all right you
did you get a scholarship well west
point it's full right that's right for
what but yes i got i was i was offered a
couple places chose west point and what
position you played offensive line okay
played tackle in high school left or
right i was left tackling high school
like guard
college was guard that was why you
smashed too slow yeah too slow and not
tall enough college you gotta be like
six eight yeah who's the guy who's
playing next to you oh you know what's
funny at army the dude uh with the
steelers
oh uh who we just got actually the raven
sign villanueva
raven signed him that's how little i
know these guys i quit uh i was at west
point for about three weeks
[Laughter]
wait i'm not being uh you got to college
too i [ __ ] got out not just the phone
and you're trying to do boot camp with
football at the same time it was funny
because while you're getting recruited
they're like
football all the football players we get
an escape we get to leave the military
stuff and go play football and it's like
nice turns out college football sucks
it was way worse than boot camp i was
like let me go back to let me go back to
[ __ ] walking
all
boot camp was at west point was like
walking and standing
now that was the first couple weeks i'm
sure it got harder but i got out of
there how do you before it got hard how
do you just cry
all you have to do is cry
you're six three 300 pounds crying
they're like all right you're [ __ ]
going home i was like i want to go home
that was really it yeah there's no
dishonorable discharge no anything like
that it's just honorable discharge
you're just honorable yeah yeah yeah
okay because day one you swear in yeah
i'm sorry i was a [ __ ] soldier
technically yeah and i've told this
before but it's funny because
technically
i did join during wartime if you
volunteer during wartime you get a medal
and i was honorably discharged so
technically i technically i'm a
decorated veteran do you have a medal no
i didn't buy it you could i could buy it
you could order it i could have ordered
it it would have been [ __ ] insane to
order that
i'm a decorator
to steal valor but technically legally
doing it yeah yeah uh but no i got there
and it was funny when i quit
because you get the first day i knew i
was in trouble because i was like
[ __ ] around we were like doing the
head shave thing all that so you're just
standing in line it's being a bunch of
other dudes we just got our uniforms and
[ __ ] you just get underwear you get tidy
whities
that's your [ __ ] uniform you gotta
walk all day and tidy whities all day
you're in sweating it's hot as [ __ ] it
was summer
uh
but while we were standing against the
wall everybody's getting their head
shaved and [ __ ] and i started like
[ __ ] around
and
a drill sergeant heard it and was like
who who's yelling and the dude next to
me was like he had you out [ __ ] round
me out right away
i was like dude what is this
uh yeah i didn't i didn't belong there
at all i just wanted
you know i was in high school so i was
like this would be cool
play like at notre dame at texas a m all
these schools yeah uh and yeah i was
i was dumb
i was a dumb [ __ ]
this is the worst way to go into boot
camp
[Applause]
what a terrible way to enter the
military
you exited pretty cool i was out dude i
got in there and i was like i'm [ __ ]
this was a huge mistake well it was
funny too because i knew i made a
mistake like yeah when when i made a
mistake like two months ahead so after i
committed i was like this is
i [ __ ] up but you know i was i was 17
or 18 at the time so he's it's new like
[ __ ] up like that i didn't know what
to do
and uh i remember the night before boot
camp i was in a hotel like with my
parents because your parents dropped you
off at like 5 a.m or 6 a.m so
i was just laying there with them and i
was like geez this is in a hotel room
and uh
were they supportive did they think this
was a good thing or they were like hey
we don't have to pay for college he goes
right we're so proud i'm so proud so
that was yeah that'll come back with yes
they've been proud of me twice
and both times catastrophic failures
that seem to last about the same amount
dude same amount
i mean truly i've had six weeks in my
entire life with my parents being proud
but uh
so
they
so while the night before boot camp i
called my friend jamal who was playing
d2 somewhere else so i called him and i
was like what's going on and he was like
i'm just playing madden we're gonna go
to a party i was like [ __ ]
i [ __ ] up like i'm in a hotel with my
parents about to go to boot camp i
should have went d2
should have went to another could you
have yeah i could have played dc yeah
yeah i the other schools i was going to
was like one double a 1a was anyone else
other schools looking at you at the time
yeah for sure who else uh
in hindsight who would you have picked
uh that was knocking so i'll tell you
after army i transferred to elon and
played one season of college football
okay so no matter where i went i was
gonna quit i quit after that full season
uh because college football did suck but
uh yeah i should have won one double a i
should have went to like duquesne or
the smaller and you think you would have
played out there
i don't know i probably wouldn't have
finished the foot the the one season i
finished at elon if i hadn't quit
west point already you can't quit like
twice back to back in like a month
although i would have did it sucked so
uh
when you hit the realization that you're
gonna leave what bothers you more like
telling your parents about this that was
annoying because they were coached
because everybody that goes to west
point cries and tries to quit everybody
does like every when you go basically
everybody obviously there's dudes that
are like patriots
that like want to be in the military
yeah yeah but uh everybody that goes
there has like a 1600 on their s.a.t and
it's kind of like a dork so when you get
into that competitive like getting
yelled at in the morning dorks [ __ ]
spaz
and uh
that's funny
uh
so yeah the parents were coached to say
you can't come home got it so when you
call your parents like hey i'm quitting
they're coached
by like drill instructors and recruiters
to be like say no say they're literally
not allowed to come home so my parents
when i called them and i was like i'm
coming home i'm [ __ ] quitting they're
like you cannot quit and i was like you
guys are [ __ ] losers
i was so mean i was like you guys you're
a [ __ ] teacher mom shut the [ __ ] up
it was it was really regrettable stuff
dude
it was embarrassing
i mean dude imagine crying on the phone
with your body and other dudes crying
waiting to get with your mama
you're a loser
and then they finally the next time i
call they're like all right of course
you can come home we were told to say
that
uh
but yeah they it was funny because when
they
this was very funny so when they drop
you off they you drop they drop you off
in regular clothes and your parents say
goodbye to you and then at the end of
the day there's a parade of all the new
cadets in front of all the parents and
now they see you marching in a uniform
head shaved at the end of the day
so
during that parade i see my mom like
waving a flag like one of those mini
flags and i walk by her and she was like
yes and i was like
in one hour
and she literally went like this dude
she goes
she dropped her flag
i'm getting the [ __ ] i was like i am
[ __ ] out of here
oh [ __ ] yeah it was a huge and what was
funny is like while you're quitting i
was still getting letters from people
back home that were like we're so proud
of you this is incredible and i was like
you're already out i'm out dude you're
already sitting on the couch i was
getting letters from people that were
like we love you we're proud of you and
i was like i'm going to community
college
yeah
uh oh that's great yeah so that was a
pretty big uh how did you fail did they
ever talk to you about it like did they
tell you they were disappointed or you
just knew no you could see it yeah yeah
i mean my dad who was once like your dad
i would imagine my dad was he a military
guy no no that was another thing he said
that i was like what if i [ __ ] die
like i was talking about it
because one day temple
recruited me temple was recruiting me
and army was recruiting me and i told my
mom i committed to temple and she cried
and i was like oh you guys like because
when army recruits you they get your
parents
you know what i mean what do you mean
they tell your parent because
if you're getting recruited to army
chances are the other schools you're
getting recruited to
at the d1 level are shitty you know it's
like eastern michigan temple right like
normal schools that anybody can get into
army is like
going to ivy league right uh so
when they're recruiting you they're like
drilling it to your parents like your
kid's gonna be a [ __ ] loser if he
goes to eastern michigan we can make him
a senator i think so your parents are
like oh you got to go to army right you
have to go to army so when i told my mom
i committed to temple she like was sad
and i didn't commit to temple i just
wanted to see what she would say and she
like cried and i was like damn so like
they get your parents so my parents were
like west point's the best place ever
uh
yeah they're like they're all in my dad
had like army hats but i remember one
time i was talking to my dad about army
and i was like what if i [ __ ] die and
he's like is that so bad is that so bad
for your country yeah i was like you're
a salesman
just don't tell me that yeah
yeah that's okay yeah i was like what if
i died is that bad to die for your
country i was like you didn't [ __ ]
serve what the [ __ ] are you talking
about yeah so there was a lot of that
so you get out and then you i get out i
transfer
immediately i go
this also sucked because i quit early
enough and west point's
boot camp is early enough
that you start in like june so i
technically quit early enough to have
time to go make another school's oh okay
preseason so i left boot camp and went
straight like a week later to elon
university in north carolina because
their coach at the time
was at lehigh and he was recruiting me
there and uh so i get to elon
and that [ __ ] that sucked
that was harder than boot camp i mean
football is college football is harder
than
west point's boot camp i'm not saying
like marines in what ways
you physically get beat up like you're
going up against girl like jacked
giant dudes that are physically
dominating you for
four hours every single day
so that sucks just beating you oh man
dude i was and i
i was like you're going up against
something
well even the safeties would like come
down dude guys that was like 180 pounds
would just [ __ ] level me dude i
sucked i [ __ ] sucked
oh man and it's [ __ ] ronnie lot over
here it was such a harsh reality because
you go from high school where i was 6'3
290 in high school i was bigger than
everybody yeah i could literally just
walk towards someone and they'd move
and then you get to college and like
those dudes are huge so the reality is
like you go from being the best guy on
your team to
the worst guy in the conference the cop
i was so bad dude when i my o-line coach
elon [ __ ] hated me he hated me and
when i quit i was like i feel like i'm
probably like one of the worst guys on
the team right and he was like yeah
you're probably
yeah when i quit he was like yeah you're
fine you're doing the right thing yeah
yeah
it was rafted that was rough
that was my whole identity my whole life
i was like i'm a football player i'm a
football player then
you find out you're not and it's like oh
[ __ ]
and then what do you do you pivot to
what so i left elon went to
harrisburg area community college so
this is all in the span of like a year
and a half my parents think i'm gonna be
like a senator
at westwood like a general
general a year yeah a year and a half
later i'm like failing at community
college sleeping on their couch washing
dishes
i mean it was like so i've been down
before like the snl thing was
it was bad but it was nothing compared
like that was bad that was like my dad
was like you're a [ __ ] and that hurt
you know what i mean and he was right at
the time i was being a [ __ ] i was
quitting everything
and uh
yeah i ended up getting into westchester
university just
studied history
that was it and you got your bachelor's
of bachelor's in history for no reason
all right graduated when i was like 23
or 20. now are you into comedy at all
during this time i just started comedy
at westchester so when i like uh like 22
years old 21 22. 22 and what age do you
get
snl
two years ago so i was 32 or 31 10 years
nine years yeah you're in 31. but see
when i when i started comedy it was only
in the summer because i would do it at
home not really at school
and then uh i would take like six months
off a year off like [ __ ] like that and
then uh
sold cars
and then i just left harrisburg moved to
philadelphia to do comedy like full-time
so i was in philly for like four years
the first year i moved to new york
that's when i got snl gosh oh first year
in yeah like right away yeah it was cool
so talk talk to me about that because
was as a kid was snl always a goal
uh when when i was a young kid yeah i
was like chris farley's the funniest guy
of all time right uh and then will
ferrell i thought was easily the
funniest dude and then uh yeah but once
i got into stand-up and like got into
stand-up i was like i'll never get snl
like that's not
i knew who i was i wasn't and i knew
what they were so i was like that'll
never i'll never get that
and then i got i got to new york and my
agents were like hey snl wants to give
you a packet a writer's packet i was
like i'm not going to be a writer i
didn't do it they're like snow wants you
to audition i was like
now what were they seeing that caught
their eye oh uh jfl okay i did pretty
well at jfl and it and you can stand up
there
yeah
and then uh yeah they were like we want
you to audition straight to the main
stage so i got yeah definitely wow and i
was still like i'm not gonna get it like
i remember being in the waiting room
with my friend reggie conquest he's he's
a comic he's very funny we were together
waiting for this
and i was like i'm never gonna get this
like this is
like i didn't care and what was your
audition what did you prepare uh just
five minutes to stand up you didn't have
characters no characters nothing just
stand up
and uh and this was still to be in front
of the camera are they still considering
you to write or both well yeah when you
audition they're not sure
but
once you knew you didn't want to write
yeah i knew i didn't want to write but
once you go through the audition and
they're like if they offered you a
writer's job it if they would have given
me a writer's job like i sat down with
lauren and he was like i'm not sure if
you're going to write or be on the cast
if you're a writer it'll just be to show
you the ropes of how things are done
here for a year and then cast but then
he called me and was like straight we'll
go straight to cast all right so let's
go back so you did five minutes who's in
the room uh it's an empty room which is
[ __ ] brutal yeah dude it's like
and also i i was saying how i didn't
care like i truly was loose didn't care
and then as soon as you walk into the
room and see the stage you're like oh
[ __ ] this and is it right there on stage
yeah yeah yeah you're standing dead
center on the main stage where they do
the monologue and all that and there's
just a camera right in front of you but
yeah right when i walked out at all it
all changed there's no execs in the dark
there is there's a table
of like lorne michaels oh he's the
writers like michael che and some of the
other executives and all that there's
just a small table to your left of
probably like eight people
and uh
here's just a camera probably from like
me to you or that wall there's a guy
behind it that's like three two one
go
you just say your name and then do five
minutes everybody laughing my hand was
shaking so i had the mic against my chin
ah these yeah it was crazy dude if those
that's a great you know how they release
like those
auditions dude if my audition gets
leaked
or is released it'll it'll be funny my
hand was truly like do you hear them
laughing at all in the dark so you're
told the whole time they're not gonna
laugh like it's gonna be quiet but the
first thing i said they laughed so i was
like oh [ __ ] i'm doing pretty well and
then like i couldn't not you're supposed
to pretend they're not there and you're
talking to the crowd but anytime they'd
laugh i'd be like
like i couldn't couldn't help it disco
is a clean skincare brand they're based
in austin texas and the truth is before
they reached out to me i was already
using their product all right your boy
over here has got the face of an
afternoon nap i want to try to touch up
these bags under my eyes and i'd already
had it before they reached out to
sponsor so i was stoked when they came
on board all disco products are created
specifically for male skin issues like
under eye bags dark circles acne razor
burn oily skin dry skin and wrinkles
okay disco products are easy to use
effective and affordable they take the
guesswork out of taking care of your
skin their disco repairing eye stick is
formulated with caffeine which is fancy
peptides and moisturizer to transform
those under eye bags after a long night
of partying gaming working or whatever
your advice may be if you want to check
out this go and try their incredible
skin care products for yourself we have
a special offer for my honeydew audience
go to letsdisco.com
honeydew or enter honeydew at checkout
for 30 off your first order that's
letsdisco.com
honeydew for 30 off your first order
thank you disco cooler weather makes it
easier to miss your signs of dehydration
like overheating or perspiration which
means it's even more important to keep
your body properly hydrated making
hydration a priority helps us feel
healthier on a day-to-day basis and
fuels us to be at our highest potential
look i take liquid iv every day i put it
in my bottle of water and i get out
there i walk the park i put it in my
bottled water i take it to the gym with
me every day a couple of them i feel
great liquid ivy is on a mission to
change the world the company is donating
four million servings in response to
coven 19. grab your favorite liquid iv
flavors nationwide at walmart or you can
get 25 off when you go to liquidive.com
and use code honeydew a checkout that's
25 off of anything you order when you
get better hydration today using promo
code honeydew at liquid
iv.com grab your favorite liquid iv
flavors nationwide at walmart or you can
get 25 off when you go to liquidive.com
and use code honeydew at checkout that's
25 off of anything you order when you
get better hydration today using promo
code honeydew at liquidive.com
um
i get done i was like i think i mean
they laughed i was told they weren't
gonna laugh
but i still i knew i was nervous like i
was shaking my arm was [ __ ] shaking
so i was like that had to be terrible i
ran into michael che that night at a
show
and i was with soder and big j
who those were the guys i like latched
on to when i moved to new york followed
them around yeah uh
and
che was like talking to them and was
like your boy did good he was funny and
i was like oh man i thought i i thought
i bombed like i was nervous and he was
like you were the least nervous by far
and that that's like and that was the
night of the audition so i was like oh
[ __ ] i might have got this then i get a
call back and i was like how soon
three days oh it's four days yeah and
they're telling you to come back
yeah you come back just to meet
everybody in the office you don't have
to do the session no more sets it's just
me
three other people that are like up for
the position or whatever
and we go around and you go room to room
and meet everybody at snl
and uh
then at the end you go sit the four of
us sat and waited in lauren michael's
office
and he would call people in one by one
to meet them but again you're waiting
they always make you wait it's like on
the audition you just wait in a green
room for like two three hours for real
before you audition yeah
it's like a technique to make you
nervous to see yeah i saw an interview
with chris rock where he talked about
how another comedian he knew at the time
was like [ __ ] this i'm not waiting and
he left but he stayed there and waited
and waited
yeah what a dumbass i mean it's snl it's
not
[ __ ] you know some [ __ ] cheese
that's audition yeah
and uh so you're sitting in this office
we're all waiting i was talking to the
other comics i i remember them it was
right when a chappelle special came out
it was two years ago like exactly two
years ago today and uh
they were like [ __ ] on chappelle's
special
and i was like oh man i'm not like these
people they're like i think it was kind
of transphobic and like all this stuff
and i was like dude
i'm never getting this job so they call
the first person in they meet with
lauren they leave after like a minute
the next person
gets called in they leave the third guy
they're like you don't even have to meet
him you can leave which that was pretty
brutal oh really yeah they were like you
can leave he didn't even get to go in to
meet lauren and then i sat another
like hour and a half by myself
in this room and i was like oh i
definitely got it like now at that point
i knew i got it
uh
why what are you thinking because the
three people there are rapid succession
in and out see ya and then it was just
me waiting
to talk to the lord yeah and there's
girl he has girls that work for him and
they there's like a separate room of
just you and these girls and they were
kind of
like oh you're waiting that's good yeah
they were they were very nice people
everybody was nice
i mean you know everybody's cool and
then uh yeah go in meet with lauren
it was cool
he says
he was like i'm gonna use you i'm just
not sure if it's writing a cast okay and
then on 9 11
i got the phone call
that says that was lauren and it was
like we're going to put you on the cast
and then september 12th they released
the information that i was gonna be on
the cast okay so they did have about one
day to vet me
so i think that's probably where it was
difficult
it's look for someone who does
you know weekly content
good luck vetting anyone that's been
doing that for 10 years you know yeah
good luck finding that but also you got
to be looking for it yeah you know
especially if you're going back that far
yeah
so you get so so the 11th you get the
call 12 hits the trades yeah
four hours later i'm getting the same
day same day i didn't realize it so i
literally same day the day got announced
that i was on snl i got like
everybody i've ever known in my life was
calling me it was like congratulations
proud of you we love you and it's funny
because i didn't have time to respond to
all of them
so like no i'll have texts today like
somebody will text me today that i
haven't heard from in a while and be
like hey congrats on the special and
then the last time they messaged me or
texted me it was like
congrats on snl this is incredible and
then the next one's like don't worry
buddy we believe in you
three hours later
i mean i was getting [ __ ] drilled
dude i'll bet what is that like what's
wait when
how did it come to you how did you find
out about it so i was so that night i
had shows at the stand so i was going to
do shows and i was like nice i just got
announced on snl i'm gonna go to the
club get some drinks it'll be fun
and uh
on the way to the club i was in the
train
and i got a text
from my agent that was like did you say
the word
uh the c word and i was like no i would
never
i don't say that word and then she was
like here's a clip of you saying it was
literally a video of me saying it and i
was like all right maybe i said it
looks like i said it yeah
but it was it was because i was in a
train i was going in and out of service
so like i was getting like texts that
were like
did you say this and then like 20
minutes later be like you need to call
me
like and then the whole way and by the
time i got to the stand like tmz was
there no no
they met you there they got there before
you did yeah
get those [ __ ] outta here crazy
yeah that and so you walk into that
situation yeah dude i'm going from open
mics to literally tmz the next day
and comics like oh you're in trouble and
so you got a little bit of a heads up
what was happening just because of the
daily communication on the train and you
walk into that yeah and do you talk to
them right there no i didn't talk to him
i just walked in did they come to you
and i was like hey man what's going on
hey you know they're like nice tmz is
like nice to you yeah they're like hey
man it's tough what's going on you got
anything to say they try to like bait
you in to be like yeah [ __ ] that yeah
yeah
yeah
uh so yeah just that was it and then i i
went on stage like while it was all
happening and i was like
i think things are bad like i was like i
think i'm in trouble yeah i was like i
don't think this is good
it was funny too because everybody
including lauren michaels the whole time
was like you're gonna be fine don't
worry this happened really yeah they
were all confident because every
everybody they've had
the last couple years gets this
treatment like they always have one or
two
like something will come up where they
tweeted something a while ago but it was
never a video of them saying a slur you
know what i mean right so the whole time
i was like no i'm not like this is bad
if they're going through my podcast like
this is bad
uh so i was kind of like i'm definitely
getting fired the whole time
um
yeah that's and then that night i'm on
the phone with like
lauren and all these people telling me
what to do like don't apologize
apologize say all this [ __ ] what's
lauren telling you lauren's
so nbc is saying here's the statement
you need to say and it's like a written
out like
what i said was inexcusable i've learned
from my mistakes like that like
paragraph you need to tweet this i was
like i'm not gonna tweet that like
that's you know that's crazy
um
but then lauren was like i just need you
to give me something
so i was like all right that's fair it's
reasonable
and uh so yeah i just had like five
minutes he was like i need something in
the next 10 minutes so i just sat there
and typed something out and tweeted it
yeah
that was it and that didn't do anything
for him no [ __ ] no i mean i sent it to
him first and he was like all right yeah
we'll we'll try post this see how it
goes and there's no apologizing
you know
nobody if there's nothing i could have
said in that moment where any all these
people that wanted my job would have
been like
oh
you know what i mean yeah when you tweet
an apology there's no it's not going to
do anything no
they're going to just rip it apart
they're going to be like he doesn't care
right you know now it's more fodder to
tear apart yeah
yeah so then when do you get the actual
call that you're not going to be
like four days later
yeah right because it was are you just
[ __ ] [ __ ] yourself like dying it
was like i wasn't like
it was just very surreal it wasn't like
i wasn't i mean don't get me wrong i was
extremely stressed out like i'll see
a video or interview with me from back
then and i'm like oh man i was different
like i was [ __ ] up it does [ __ ] you up
like getting i can't getting like
canceled or whatever however you want to
say it
uh but it's more than being canceled
it's it's this rise
this you know historic show yeah this
childhood dream
and canceled
all in like a week yeah all in a week
like there's more than just canceling
and being cancelled and
but see here's the thing that i look i'm
a student of the game so i know who you
are and we have never met before today
and i've like watched your
um
your your [ __ ] sketches right now
you're killing it dude your [ __ ] is it
is funnier than the stuff i see on snl
thank you
um
it's nice to hear though that they
thought that they were going to be all
right and they thought you really were
going to make it through this yeah
what's the who called you to tell you no
uh lauren
lauren he himself yeah yeah yeah well it
was at first it was like because he
always talked to somebody first he was
just like yeah it's not gonna
it's not gonna happen
and that's it and i was like yeah i know
i was like yeah i had a feeling
but he was
so then you you have time to write like
a they offered me i could either resign
i could resign or they could fire me
they offered me that and i was like now
you're gonna have to you guys are gonna
have to fire me this is gonna be on you
um
and did they yeah they fired me yeah
yeah i mean is that what they actually
it's
putting the trades or whatever like that
it was a they fired you yeah yeah um
[Music]
yeah
so that so then i got to they they like
timed it so that we're gonna say we
let you go
you can time it so like i put something
out at the same time like it's all very
it's weird it's orchestrated yeah and uh
yeah
and they're like let's see can you show
us the tweet you're gonna put out about
getting fired i was like yeah here it is
this is what i'm gonna say and they're
like all right that's fine
yeah and what's it been like seeing like
che and those guys on the scene since
then oh i get along with all those guys
yeah yeah they didn't fire me no but i
think like like i've heard
rumors
it's not true i don't know if it's true
but like him and like some of the other
cast members like tried to keep me yeah
so yeah i like those guys so what
happens to you
personally after this like where do you
go emotionally personally this first day
after this ah yeah i don't know i can
consider quitting do you consider none
because i mean there was a part of me
that was like this is it not cool but
like this is crazy like this is all like
i was on cnn and like it was crazy so
yeah you were everywhere i wouldn't say
it was cool but it was it was definitely
like exciting in some sense
you know to go from zero to that
um
i was worried you know you're worried
about like other things coming out or
like
you just get very paranoid i'll still
say still vtsd oh yeah i would imagine
like they're gonna go dig through
something i said and take it this way
and get that out there just keep piling
it on i put that special out yesterday
and all day i was like it's the same i
did rogan's podcast and it was the same
feeling i was like what are they gonna
pull out this is gonna be something bad
and then i put out that special
yesterday and i was like this is gonna
be bad so like it does
i don't want to get too emotional yeah
but it does take something from you like
i don't
i lost a lot of joy in doing things
you know what i mean yeah and do you
find yourself overthinking now for a
certain extent for sure do you think
it's a detriment though
i don't i don't
i don't overthink things in comedy like
uh like i'll do something and say
something and put it out and then when
i'm done then i'm like oh [ __ ] what did
i just do what did i put out here's how
it's gonna be taken
this is bad people and it's it's a it's
tough to explain to people
because every every fans like [ __ ] it
dude [ __ ] them put it out and it's like
i don't it [ __ ] me up you know
i can imagine it was awesome yeah
tell me about your parents then you said
what happened they were good they were
like proud and supportive and even when
i got like in trouble they were like
we're with you don't worry
so that was nice
yeah and then my dad did like a [ __ ]
interview with like a local paper and i
called him i was like listen don't talk
to anybody
because that's what happens is like
as soon as you're in the spotlight like
that everybody somehow gets everybody
you know his phone number like i was
getting phone calls from everybody my
family was getting phone calls really
yeah out of nowhere like there's no
quotes [ __ ] they're trying to get you to
say something
and so i like had to call my dad be like
make sure you don't say anything and he
was like ah
and i was like what he was like i just
did an interview i was like don't do any
[ __ ] interviews he didn't interview
he did an interview that was like my son
did nothing wrong yeah it was nice
yeah i think they were shell-shocked too
you know because they it was kind of
like west point where they had like a
lot of time to be probably proud and
yeah i don't want to say braggadocios
but they were you know they're with
their friends right our sons going to
west point they're like they had a
couple days to be like our son's gonna
be on saturday night live yeah and
everyone was like oh great and then as
soon as you get canceled it's like
[ __ ] loser you know now has that ever
happened to anyone on snl before where
they've been
cast and then fired no prior to actually
getting to the show no you're the you're
the owner of history yes you made snl
history i did make it without ever
no you set foot on that stage i did you
all did technically i did set foot on
the stage but uh
yeah i don't know it's weird to say
because it makes me look like uh
i don't know i don't want to sound like
like they're all nice everybody at snl
was nice to me
there's no real heart i don't have any
hard feelings with snl right they tried
and i understood why they fired me you
know what i mean yeah of course i know
what you mean yeah but but i do i loved
seeing like uh i watched norm back you i
saw a lot
so tell me about that who um
who from the old cast came forward and
and supported you um
i remember
seeing david spade and bill burr and jim
jeffries did like a clip on his show
about it and that was cool to watch that
was nice uh
but yeah like norm
mcdonald that he was very vocal who's
like one of my he's my guy right i mean
come on he's incredible in fact i just
watched his special last week again this
is the best
and uh
yeah that was cool because he put out a
thing like while i was he tweeted
something like congratulations yes and
it was like while i was definitely
getting fired
and he didn't think i was going to get
fired right so he was like i didn't
think like it almost seemed like he was
being a dick
to outside people like tweeting like
people were trying to ruin it this is
the best day of your life like while i
was getting fired
um
but yeah he called talked to yeah
everybody
they were all pretty supportive
it was yeah it was crazy it was wild
so what's the how long did you wait to
get back on stage and do stan oh that
night i just kept doing it yeah and and
people were like talk about it on stage
that night yeah yeah did you for sure
yeah there was a night the night i got
fired i went and did a show and ari it
was me and ari on stage talking about it
it was pretty cool it was fun but then
of course there's reporters going to
shows recording everything you say
posting it posting articles about it is
like damn how long was that happening
that was probably about a month but it
still sticks with you coming to f it
still sticks with you so now like
and like on stage i'd see people like
talking to each other because that's
what happens in clubs like people talk
at the table and i'd be like are they
[ __ ]
talking [ __ ] like it's just in your head
for so long where you're like everybody
hates me it's a negative thing a
negative thing yeah which is not good to
have on stage no to like look out to a
crowd of people and be like half them
hate me right yeah it's wild but nobody
ever nobody said one thing to my face
ever no never you've never had anyone
come up to you no no one's low back no
one has ever
in person come up and be like [ __ ] you
ever
so
it's how it works yeah everybody just
tweets and then when they see you in
person they're like oh hey how are you
these fake [ __ ] yeah but that was
another thing that i like
i understand because i have a podcast
when i was an open miker in philly
trashing everybody every single comedian
i'd be like oh they [ __ ] suck i'm
[ __ ] better than that like all the
time so like
when people would do that to me i'd be
like all right i get it i understand i
know i know the place of like insecurity
that comes from to like trash another
comic on your podcast it's just you know
yeah so like i get it i don't no hard
feelings towards any of them either
so
like creatively and strategically how
has this changed you and because you
obviously pivoted and
you've moved right forward so what
you know do you work a different way now
do you no
so what it what did it do did it
motivate you more in the long run do you
think it's
yeah i would i would assume it mo
because i don't know how else i would
have been if i did or didn't get it
would you have done these sketches and
stuff that you do now had it not been
for
this whole snl i don't think so i think
if i got if i didn't even get offered
snl nobody would have ever looked into
my podcast or tried to get me in trouble
because that was like one of the few
jobs i could have gotten where people
were like look at how shitty this guy is
um listen i probably would have been
doing
acting like tv [ __ ] and all that because
at the time i was i was getting a lot
you were of auditions and stuff like
that so yeah i probably would have just
been in shows
you know but do you find like for
instance with your special right now
that's out on what your youtube yeah
right
do you find do you prefer it that way
that you just
did you even try to shop it around did
you just say it was funny it might not
either yeah my agents were like let's
let's hold off on this let's try to shop
this to like hbo or netflix i was like
they're not going to [ __ ] buy it
right nobody's going to buy this for and
also it's going to be a year of emails
back and forth and [ __ ] for to get a
no then this [ __ ] could have been up a
year ago yeah yeah of course uh and the
goal is just put it out on youtube and
hopefully the next special gets picked
up right you know right because at this
point now i kind of have to prove that
i'm good
you know a lot of times
uh
they just kind of pick you they tap you
they're like all right this is our guy
we're going to put him on comedy central
on hbo
whereas now i kind of have to make my
own stuff and be like here's a body of
work
now can i be on something
um and that's a cool route to go alright
it is but even if you can't be on these
other things yeah those are places you
can be of course and youtube is a viable
place to be of course honestly you're
probably getting more views on your
sketches there than snl is certainly you
know
i don't know about views compared to nbc
but
i i would say it's probably competitive
to be honest i hope that'd be nice but
uh it used to be when you pitched shows
it was um well we're cable we don't have
a lot of money it was all that [ __ ]
and then yeah yeah well i remember being
in a meeting one time and somebody said
that i was like well can you what what
uh networks can do your kids know
what what network is your kid watching
they're not watching nbc abc cbs or
[ __ ] fox they're watching nickelodeon
they're watching mtv they're watching
all these other things so get the [ __ ]
out of here with that k boy you are
where all the money is yeah
yeah i mean
youtube's yeah it's perfectly like i
think the views i would get on youtube
versus if i sold my special to like a
streaming service is definitely better
definitely better and in the long term
like
getting i don't know how much money if i
would have sold it to a streaming
service you get like 40 grand or
something i have no idea did you ever
read the fine print that appears when
you start browsing in incognito mode it
says that your activity might still be
visible to your employer your school or
your internet service provider how can
they call it incognito to really stop
people from seeing the sites you visit
you need to do what i do and use
expressvpn think about all the times you
used wi-fi at a coffee shop or a hotel
or even at your parents house with that
expressvpn every site you visit could be
logged by the admin of that network and
that's still true even when you're in
incognito mode i mean do you really want
your parents to see what you've been
looking at you definitely don't what's
more your home internet provider can
also see and record your browsing data
in the us they're legally allowed to
sell that data to advertisers expressvpn
is an app that encrypts all of your
network data and re-routes it through a
network of secure servers so that your
private online activity stays just that
private expressvpn works on all your
devices and is super easy to use the app
literally has one button you tap it to
connect and your browsing activity is
secure from prying eyes so stop letting
strangers invade your online privacy
protect yourself at
expressvpn.com honeydew use my link at
expressvpn.com
honeydew to get three extra months free
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s
vpn.com
honeydew to learn more keeps is back and
you know the guys at the studio are
using keeps i have friends that use
keeps uh because two out of three men
will experience some form of hair loss
by the time they're 35 that's young
y'all that's young keeps offers a simple
stress-free way to keep your hair all
right convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications are
delivered straight to your door every
three months all right so you're not
having to to leave your home it's a low
cost treatment start at just 10 bucks a
month and keeps does offer generic
versions keeps has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors
prevention is key all right so
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so you gotta act fast and
here's what you gotta do if you're ready
to take action and prevent hair loss
go to keeps.com that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash honeydew to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash honeydew to get
your first month free k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash honeydew now let's get back to the
duke what i love about this this this
podcasting has also opened up this
community of comedians that i love like
getting to sit with you and all these
other guys like the new york guys the la
guys and
the thing i like about it is
like
it's now
it's peer-to-peer sure and it's direct
to consumer yeah we are helping one
another and we're putting it right out
there for everybody else right yeah you
don't have to wait for a netflix to or
an hbo or whoever amazon to give you
this green light to be put out there you
can go to your friends and do their
shows and then put it right out to all
the people who love you so i love the
it's all direct to consumer and
peer-to-peer you don't need that
[ __ ] anymore and what's nice is when
you put like the special i put on
youtube it's just it's shared by every
comedian everybody's
pulling for each other and it's it's
pretty nice it's less competitive
because i would imagine i've only i've
only been this is the first special ever
put out i've only been kind of
headlining within this
era of comedy i would imagine before
when like four guys got a special a year
it was pretty [ __ ] cutthroat and
comedians would probably be like ah [ __ ]
that guy right [ __ ] this now who could
who could be mad that i put a youtube
special out right no anybody can do it
anyone can do it so
it's not like i'm taking someone's spot
i'm just like there was room for all of
us before sure there was yeah there's so
much more room for all of us with the
internet now yeah i mean there's so much
and if you don't like it [ __ ] move on
yeah there's plenty more for you to see
of course
so nice man i i you know i'm i really
think it's impressive and uh
you know you've had to dig out of quite
a hole yeah and to keep your focus yeah
and to stay positive like what did you
what are some of the things you did to
stay positive during that time
nothing
i'm pretty negative
literally nothing
stand up that's it but what gate see
that's the only thing through my hardest
times like i remember
splitting from my daughter's mom and
stuff and just freaking out about losing
feeling like i'm gonna lose my kid and
oh man and it was stand up it was not i
mean it didn't matter whether i was on
that stage for 12 minutes or an hour
for whatever reason none of my troubles
go through my mind none of them none not
one and i'm like man that's the only
place i'm 100 free is up there where i
don't think about the [ __ ] in my
life
that's [ __ ] crazy how do i how do i
get that time to be more yeah either
that or drinking
yeah yeah you could just drink right out
of that
didn't you drink more during that did
you all right so you went you did i
didn't like turn to the bottle but yeah
i mean well it was also it coincided
with me moving to new york and doing
shows every night
so if you're doing shows every night and
you drink you're gonna drink yeah you
know
so that yeah and and then i finally got
a little bit of money because normally
up until snl had zero dollars
did they pay you anything from that yeah
i got like the first season's worth oh
okay say paid you for a full season yeah
uh they pay you
what are you allowed to do you get half
a c i got 50 000 oh wow all right
but at the time that was
i mean it's at least it's something to
keep you
motivated
dude that was the most money i ever had
in my life yeah yeah but it's going to
go quick in new york if you don't go in
new york i got rid of it i spent it in a
month
i bought a chevy cruze and paid my
student debt
that was it sucks that you had to give
it the [ __ ] student debt yeah yeah
yeah gave it to student debt i paid the
whole thing
god damn um should have stayed at west
point yeah there's no students there
truly
yeah but i might be dead he probably
would be dead yeah so i would have been
a big [ __ ] target yeah they'd be
[ __ ] you up out there dude yeah uh
yeah i don't know when did you realize
or did you have a moment during that
where you're like oh this is it's
getting to me more than i thought it was
or i don't know you said it [ __ ] with
you really [ __ ] with you but when are
the moments that would get to you it's
almost like it's almost like when
you're depressed like you don't realize
it until you're done right that's what
i'm saying like i didn't i didn't
realize it until like recently how
[ __ ] up like
and it's still it's still
what do you look back and see you
mentioned seeing yourself on it after
yeah you're just saying like a clip or
something yeah where i'm like oh i'm
definitely
different
uh it affects like relationships
for sure like all of a sudden the only
thing i cared about was stand-up versus
other you know it it [ __ ] you up i
don't know how else to it's almost
impossible to describe to anybody that
hasn't
experienced yeah
but
yeah i don't know you do it's it's it's
exactly like being like depressed where
you like while you're in it i was kind
of like blocking it out i was like
people would be like are you all right
i'd be like i'm fine
like the whole time i was like this is
nothing i'm fine
and then when you get done you're like
damn i was [ __ ] up that hurt
you know
yeah i mean you're literally pushed off
the mountaintop yeah bro yeah and people
are happy and happy about it people are
very happy yeah for sure
did you have any but you never got
confronted you said nobody came out
nobody ever confronted me did you ever
hear any [ __ ] behind your back
people on twitter you're like i don't
even know this [ __ ] person oh i do i
don't know i mean a bunch of these
comics would come out and be like [ __ ]
him i met him once he's a piece of [ __ ]
it's like what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah dude
i've had several comedians
like one lady tweeted she met me for
like i knew when she met me she met me
for like 15 minutes
she was like yeah [ __ ] him i never liked
that guy it's like you're not crazy
you've met for 15 years yeah yeah and
then of course
it's funny because i have fans now so
like if somebody tweets at me or just
talk [ __ ] now people are just like is
this you and it's just a tweet of them
saying the n word like two years ago
and it's like shut the [ __ ] up you idiot
right yeah i don't think people
understand how this works
like if you throw stones like that if
you're like hey look at what this guy
[ __ ] that guy for saying that people are
just going to look what you've done yeah
let me go back through you're so here's
10 minutes of you screaming the n-word
on a podcast you [ __ ] dunks yeah yeah
yeah so i try not to i try not to do
that to people i try not to be like hey
look at this but
everyone smile i'll get someone
you know
do you think it motivated you in a way
to to
to do more
yeah definitely i mean
it's hard because i
i talked to
some comics about this
i talked to louis about this louis ck
about like how i was like well now i
want to prove myself like i was like i
want to prove that people were a that
they were right to pick me because that
was kind of a
that was kind of a prevailing theme
where people would be like
he would have never done well there this
was a mistake all that stuff
uh so there's a part where you like want
to prove them wrong and be good
and uh he was like you don't have to
don't he's like you don't have to prove
anything you do it for yourself
so like i've tried to i've tried to
adopt that
like i'm not trying to prove prove
proved what to who that's what you do
yes that's kind of all it is yeah and uh
yeah
do you see yourself if i hate talking
seriously about anything you have to
this is tough dude that's hard very
comfortable i want to know um do you see
yourself acting again in other things if
the opportunity presents itself are you
interested or are you just like yeah
that's sour i'd like to do that i'd like
to do that but i'm not i i would imagine
it's not going to be on like a sitcom or
like a family show so hopefully it would
just be a project that would
again be with like my friends which is
kind of what we're doing with these the
guys we do those gillian keep sketches
with that's john mcever and tommy pope
and all my my
friends from back home that like
we just can make stuff ourselves and you
do a great job perfectly capable of
making it ourselves and then why not
right yeah and we don't have to listen
to any executive notes no there's none
of this [ __ ] yeah somebody bought
one of our shows yeah then you got a
problem
yeah
they're paying you to put up with the
[ __ ] yeah and uh
and we're perfectly capable now that
we have a patreon on matt and chains and
i'm making money from touring and we
make enough money that we can produce
like pretty high quality stuff they're
very high quality yeah their [ __ ] looks
great yeah
it does it really does look good do any
of the snl people hit you up about your
stuff when they see it they do yeah yeah
yeah oh that's [ __ ] i sent them to
lauren do you really yeah what's he said
he thinks they're good
so that's got to feel good yeah yeah
yeah he's just
have you heard from him since
yeah i talked to him you do yeah i've
sent him i've talked to him about those
sketches and things like that yeah and
he still makes the time or whatever he
does that's great yeah he he goes out of
his way to like make some time which is
nice yeah you know
it's at least he could do so
it's not at least it's not the least you
do i mean literally the least he could
have done it was just like yeah see you
yeah they could be which is what you
wrote which is what you would kind of
expect but i was surprised to hear you
got money i think they
i think there was some accountability on
their part to be like sorry about that
we just picked up picked you up and got
you killed
you know what i mean that's like that is
kind of like a
if they had a soul which they might
they're like that was [ __ ] up sorry
about that good luck with your life good
luck here's the chevy cruze
here's get back out there
time to go home and wash dishes again
the car your dreams that's it did you
even con you never considered doing that
or anything though did you doing snl no
no no
no no no no no no i mean that was what
else would i [ __ ] do especially
especially now i got that on my resume
yeah what are you gonna do coming home
if you google me that's not good i'm not
getting a [ __ ] job anyway i've never
googled myself ever you will not find
ryan stickler my google search hi google
who [ __ ] that dude i search i still look
do you oh yeah i'm gonna do it today
don't watch out it's never good it's not
going to be you want to do it
last time somebody did it it said they
said they sent me something that said
ryan sickler wife and i've never been
married i've been engaged but never
married and i'm like yeah that's not
even real that's not even real and then
all these other my uh someone sent me
what i'm worth my net worth
who the [ __ ] is this ride
my ass yeah there's some weird another
one when your name gets into that like
ether whatever that is they
there's all these like weird bots that
like put up there's there's i don't know
how you know how to describe them
there's one of mine that's like clearly
just an indian bot
that's like he is very rich he drives
several cars several it's like all this
you know it's broken english like yeah
uh
but yeah dude i still re i read the
comments i do all that yeah
what's the um
what's the one thing that that sticks
with you the most from it like is there
a comment that you really stuck at you
or that you think about
no not one in particular and i don't
know when you think about this now all
right so let me ask you this question
the frequency of
the amount of times you think about this
incident oh daily it's still daily oh of
course it's not any less every other day
it's definitely less it's definitely
less so it used to be all day long every
day oh yeah and the time is now less per
day less per day certainly what do you
think about
during the day like when these thoughts
cross
notre dame toledo this week
we got toledo coming into town
uh
what do i think about it no no think
about this what do you think about
huh
well i don't know i'm not sure exactly
do you have regret
no
no definitely no regret okay about like
because i would have done the podcast
yeah no matter what i regret
uh
no i guess i don't good i don't think i
mean i'm not asking you i'm just curious
yeah i don't think so it's it that's one
thing what i'm i say good because you're
not i don't hear you saying i regret
losing snl i regret you you're saying no
no i
that's one thing i've been kind of proud
of myself about is not
regretting that stuff like not letting
that get to me
there's been a there was a i'll tell you
what the first
like
so i got hired
september september 12th and then i
think the first episode was like two
weeks later
oh wow so like right away i remember
that night i was home by myself i
watched that first episode
uh
who was it might have been woody
harrelson oh
i could be wrong on that and you're
watching oh
[ __ ] i forget i know
who's the girl who sings bad guy i'm a
bad billy eilish oh he was the musical
guy i remember that i remember sitting
there watching it like damn
i would have been there
and like
do you watch it still
no it's it's on it's usually on like at
clubs yeah like when you're doing
stand-up you get done there's like on in
the bar or something i'll see you and be
like the shit's
[ __ ] garbage that's why it's so bad
dude
there are some sketches that are very
good and i know the people that work
there that are very
very funny talented people but
you know it's rehearsed it's on national
television it's
it's like it's live so of course it's
gonna be clunky and they've given i
think they've stopped trying to
i don't know lauren said something
interesting where he was like
everybody's favorite is when they were
in high school
that's when they're like that's when it
was funny and that's always been the
case and now i think recently
it's even more so because now it's even
it's even
way more political i believe than it
used to be you know
like it felt like they used to make fun
of both sides pretty oh yeah like they'd
have both presidential candidates it
looks like mondale and reagan they were
bashing yeah so they had like they had
alec baldwin as trump and he was like a
fat [ __ ] idiot and then they had jim
carrey come on like yeah that's right
i'm i'm cool joe biden yeah it's like
dude joe biden can't talk yeah just get
a guy who's incoherent to be him if you
want to make fun of make fun of both
don't make jim carrey
cool wearing aviators as joe biden um
[Music]
yeah and they they did they did yeah
ruth bader gidsberg dying they were like
it's like be funny shut up
uh but yeah i don't wanna i try not to
trash snl because that you know
it looks it looks
yeah to me it looks kind of [ __ ]
petty yeah like a sore loser like i got
fired so you know yeah but i will say
like i don't know how many people have
really gone through this cancel culture
thing and and still stayed where you are
kept your head level you seem like
you've kept your head above the water
you're moving forward successfully
um that's not it's not easy to do that
just
regularly in this goddamn business well
i appreciate it yes
i'm gonna try to give myself some credit
you do that's what i want to say like
i'm not i look i i say this all the time
the other day yesterday for the first
time and i can't tell you how long i
looked in the mirror and i was like hey
good job
you're doing good yeah you lost weight
yeah doing the right tours about the
star puck you know because i never do
that i always look in the mirror if i do
and say like what the [ __ ] are you doing
you know what i mean like god damn dude
every time you know i will never love
about the the moving forward thing and
uh having gotten cancer i got cancelled
i had nothing before i got canceled so
that's new no almost no one has that
that's a good point so you're not so
obviously i'm gonna keep moving forward
yeah everybody else had to give
something up yeah uh
and yeah a lot of like
not many people have been cancelled for
something they've said
most of the time it's you get cancelled
for something you've done that's
interesting i'm one of the few guys to
get really fired for something they said
it's like me and kramer
yeah his was vicious you know what
though his was vicious but also
where was that was that
so i did a show there last night and i
was like that was the first time i ever
did a show there oh yeah like damn this
is where it happens
i was talking to some comics about this
the other night too like that happened a
while ago that had to be it was like one
of the first times early cell phone
video first time or something right or
the camera caught like he got drilled on
the first camera video and someone was
telling me that when tmz or whoever the
hollywood uh does their tours when they
stop in front of the laugh factory it's
not like you'll see committee go this is
where michael richards is
not this is where you could see blah
blah blah when i saw the stage last
night for the first time i was like
there's the balcony there it is that's
it there it is that's where kramer went
down and went nuts and so he had like he
had to go he went on tv and like on
letterman and like cried kind of and
apologize which i'm not judging him
because i understand the stress of that
uh but he he was already famous right so
he had a lot to lose he did and he was
losing it you could watch him lose it
like with me i didn't lose anything so
it was a little easier like your
american express contract didn't yeah i
didn't even know yeah i had zero dollars
i had zero dollars
yeah yeah so i wasn't like oh my life's
in shambles i was like no i'm still
living in a hallway in queens yeah
back to i was like wow that was a crazy
week
what a week in comedy back to where i
was last week last week yeah yeah
man and but i'm saying it's impressive
that it didn't [ __ ] derail you and
yeah well i think i think one thing it
could have done is i could have leaned
into being like a [ __ ] free speech
guy and like i'm i am right wing i am
like you know what i mean and that could
have been very lucrative but yeah that's
not who i am i wasn't going to become
like a and there's nothing wrong with
being free speech because free speech is
important yeah obviously but like
it's not going to be your mantra movie
no
i think it's i think as soon as you get
sucked in to being like if i if i like
let being canceled define who i was and
like
talked about it i mean i talked about on
every [ __ ] pocket but
if you let it like consume who you are
and what you're creating that's how you
lose
you know what i mean that's like
actually getting canceled meanwhile the
only way to not get canceled is to just
keep moving and keep doing comedy
because that's what my [ __ ] job is
that's it like if i let that consume me
and i was like every day i was like
i don't know
you know what i mean yeah of course yeah
um so i didn't tell you this before we
started the show but it's something i
ask everybody their first time on the
show
um especially now after everything we've
talked about um and that's advice you
would give to your 16 year old self
and it could be anything you [ __ ]
want it to be yeah but i'm curious what
sitting here through everything you've
been through now
going back to your 16 year old self
what would you say
uh
don't cry at boot camp
definitely just quit don't let everyone
watch you cry
i mean go look
i'm happy with where i'm at career like
in my life so everything kind of led me
to this like maybe if i went to a
regular d2 school played football there
i'd be a salesman in pennsylvania yeah
and that's fine there's nothing wrong
with that but
i like what i do now so kind of
everything
got me here
it goes the way it's supposed to go
maybe i'd say like sometimes everybody
in the house knows you're jerking off in
the shower
everybody everyone in the family knows
that was revealed to me recently what do
you mean uh my sisters were just like
you know everyone knew you were jerking
off in the shower and i was like what
they're telling you like how do you guys
know they're like you're in the shower
for an hour every
day
so i'd let 16 years old my steps on his
mom i'm like he's he's jerking off in
there she's like he is not i'm like
trust me yes he is he's been in there
for 45 minutes and p.s i was 16 with a
dick he is definitely in there doing
that right now yeah i'm like how come
every time we walk in he's taking his
[ __ ] for 45 minutes but it never smells
like [ __ ]
never smells like [ __ ] in here he's
cranking one out yeah
uh yeah i don't know what would you say
what'd you go with i'm sure you've had
my 16 year old self oh man i don't i
don't know i don't remember mine but i
know 16 was when my father died so i
would definitely say
just i mean i know i would say stick
this [ __ ] out because it gets way far
better sure but it's going to suck for
about 30 [ __ ] years oh
how'd your father pass if you don't mind
me uh hard it's well
it was ruled a heart attack when he
passed but then
it was closed no this was 89. yeah so
years later when i turned his same age
42 six years ago i [ __ ] start having
all these health problems kidney stones
all this [ __ ] they take me in
it's they're thinking i have cancer all
this [ __ ] six months in the testing they
find out i have this like blood disease
in my legs it's called factor five light
and and it's
just my blood's prone to being thicker
which makes me susceptible to clots
and now going back through everything
they're like there's a really good
chance that your father's death wasn't a
heart attack and it may have actually
been this because my mom doesn't have it
and neither do my brothers wow so
there's a chance 30 some years later i
find out that
his [ __ ] was yeah maybe something
something yeah
yeah so i gotta watch my [ __ ] 16 year
old mate yeah maybe
invest in pfizer
pfizer or vaccines
you make some money i don't know people
talk about crypto i'm like i still
wouldn't give my money i would you know
what yeah you know what if i'm gonna do
an investment i would do you know duff
mckagan from guns n roses the base
player yeah
he made more money back in the day
investing in starbucks than he did on
gnr damn
and he got it yeah early on starbucks
yeah
yeah and that just kaboom because if i
was 16 i couldn't be like delete the
podcast no i'd be 16 i'd be like what
the [ __ ] what's up don't cry at [ __ ]
west point don't go at west point spells
great stop crying in front of people
[ __ ] giant
did you cry when you got canceled uh no
i don't think so at least in private i i
swear to god i believe you i swear to
god i don't remember i remember times
getting like that like
you know like when you like lose your
breath a little but
i remember yeah i remember this was the
closest i came i was i was drunk with
some comics at the stand and we were
fighting about it and i was like
yeah
i was like i gotta go to the [ __ ]
bathroom dude i can't cry at the [ __ ]
club
[Laughter]
thank you for coming thanks for having
me yeah please promote everything again
yeah just check out uh gillian keebs
youtube channel that's my special and
then all the sketches me and my friends
are making and then uh matt and shane's
secret podcast all right yeah check out
that special and uh as always ryan
sickler on all social media ryan
sickler.com we'll talk to you all next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]